انقضاء الساعات الثقيله يصبح ما بعدها
اثقل
ويصبحوا هذا المشهد حلما وماضيا في اذهان
ووجداني من عاصر الدقيقه الفارقه او اقصر
هكذا كانت المدينه قبل الكارثه واللحظه
القادمه نادرا ما توثقها عدسه اللح
ظه لم تنشا فيها بؤره زلزال تحت هذه الارض
لا التي اقف عليها بل في المركز على بعد
عشرات الكيلومترات وعمق 300 كيلومترا
واكثر هنا لدرجه الزلزال الدور الاكبر هذه
هزه اولى بقوه 6 درجات او هزه ارتداديه
بقوه خمس درجات
لاحقت زلزالا يفوقها قوه في درجه على
الاقل علميا الهزه اقل وطء لكن هذا البيت
لم يسقط تداعى وانهار بحكم قدمه او سوء
معايير بناءه كارثه قد تحل بعشرات السكان
وربما بعض الماره ليسوا ارقاما بل الارواح
كانت امنه قبل ان تفاجئها الطبيعه
لكن امامك كارثه اكبر بالمقاييس والعواقب
ينظر الى دمار منزل او اثنين على انه
اضرار ضئيله وما سنوشك على محاكاته الان
نكبه عاشتها هايتي في 2010 كاليفورنيا
الامريكيه عام 89 تشيلي عامي 60 و2/2010
وبقاع اخرى وقف سكانها المحظوظون منهم
امام خراب وترك الالاف ضحايا تحت الالقاب
هذا ما حل بجنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا بعد
هذه اللحظه كل دقيقه بحساب وكل ثانيه
بنفسه هناك كانت غرفه النوم وهناك غرفه
المعيشه او المطبخ او الباب
كل ما كان اصبح ركاما يتسابق الوقت لرفعه
مع الموت والحياه الانقاذ والانقاذ
الامل والالم